لقد تحدثت سابقًا إلى الرئيس التنفيذي
لنادي برايتون هوف ألبيون لكرة القدم ،
وبدأت بسؤاله عما إذا كان يوافق على
هذا التقييم
إذا كان رئيس هذا الدوري الممتاز الجديد
لديه حقًا نقطة في
التحدث إلى شباب مختلفين
عن أولئك الذين أتحدث معهم
لأن الشباب الذين أتحدث
معهم يريدون منافسة جيدة ، فهم يريدون كرة قدم مثيرة ، فهم يريدون أن تكون المنافسات تنافسية قدر الإمكان حتى لا تفوز الأندية الكبيرة بالمباريات دائمًا أو بالتأكيد لا تفوز بها بفارق كبير ،
لذا  يجب أن تتحدث إلى
أشخاص مختلفين تمامًا
بالنسبة إلينا منذ أكثر من 150 عامًا
، كانت كرة القدم موجودة في
أندية منافسة صحية بعد سنوات جيدة من السنوات السيئة ،
وفازت بالمباريات ، وخسرت المباريات والفوز
بالبطولات ، وفقدت الجوائز
التي تعد جزءًا
من الدراما ، والمخاطرة بالعاطفة التي
يذهب في الواقع لإنشاء قصة
حول أكبر رياضة في
العالم إذا بدأت في تركيز الثروة
والسلطة في أيدي عدد قليل من
الأندية الصغيرة التي  ربح كل شيء
طوال الوقت بهوامش كبيرة ، ثم
بصراحة ، سنقوم بإيقاف تشغيل ليس
فقط الشباب
ولكن كبار السن أيضًا وهذا
ليس ما نحن بصدده ، هذا ليس ما تدور حوله
هذه الرياضة حول
بول ، أريد فقط أن أسمع مجرد
أكثر من ذلك بقليل
أه من الرئيس الجديد
لدوري السوبر الأوروبي هذا بالطبع ، لقد فقد رئيس
ريال مدريد
اهتمامًا كبيرًا بكرة القدم ،
أولاً علينا أن نحلل سبب عدم اهتمام 40 من
الشباب الذين
تتراوح أعمارهم بين 16 و 25 عامًا بهذا.
فلماذا لا يهتمون
بكرة القدم جيدًا لأن هناك عددًا كبيرًا جدًا من
المباريات ذات الجودة الرديئة
ولا يهتمون بامتلاك
منصات أخرى للترفيه عن أنفسهم
بهذه الحقيقة هي أنهم لن
يطردونا من دوري الأبطال.
لم تصنع لا مدينة ولا أحد منهم ،
أنا متأكد من أنني متأكد تمامًا ليس من
الدوري الإسباني
من لا شيء ، ردك
جيدًا لا يمكنني التحدث عن
مستوى المنافسة في دوريه
ولكن ما يمكنني التحدث عنه  o عبارة عن منافسة
في الدوري الممتاز حيث
تمنح الفرق الأصغر ذات المركز الأدنى بانتظام أكبر
الفرق
مباريات صعبة ، ولا يعني ذلك أن
نقول إننا فزنا بجميع تلك المباريات التي
لا نتوقع تقريبًا الفوز بها في كل تلك المباريات
لأن هناك بالفعل تباينًا كبيرًا
بين ثروة وقوة
الأندية الكبرى في الدوري الممتاز
وتلك الموجودة منا
في هذا المستوى ، لذا ما يمكنني قوله هو أن
هناك قدرًا هائلاً من كرة القدم التنافسية التي يتم
لعبها في الدوري الممتاز ،
هناك عدد قليل جدًا  الألعاب التي ندخل فيها
إلى تلك الألعاب ونحن نعلم
جيدًا النتيجة التي
ستكون عليها ، فهناك عدد قليل جدًا من الألعاب التي تكون عبارة عن
مطاط ميت ، وهناك عدد قليل جدًا من الألعاب
التي لا تجتذب جمهورًا جيدًا ،
وهناك عدد قليل جدًا من الألعاب التي لا تجذب عددًا
كبيرًا  قدر من الاهتمام من وسائل الإعلام
ليس فقط في هذا البلد
ولكن في جميع أنحاء العالم ولكن بالطبع
قد يكون الأمر مختلفًا في إسبانيا ولا يمكننا
التحدث باسم الدوري الأسباني ومن
الواضح أنه يحق له تمامًا الحصول على مباراة خاصة به.
ملاحظات حول ذلك ولكنها ليست
شيئًا نراه في الدوري الإنجليزي الممتاز